big time celebrity chrissy teigen now
getting a taste of the left's cancel
culture
multiple retailers distancing themselves
from the former model and pulling her
cookware line
after several startling accusations of
cyberbullying from the past resurfaced
one example reality star courtney
studden
claims that the former model sent
abusive tweets and direct messages when
she was only
16 years old with one shocking private
message where
teagan allegedly told stodden to commit
suicide taken since apologizing for the
decades-old online harassment
but starting claims she hasn't heard
from her directly
greg reep meets so that's true
it is true chrissy teigen is the truest
truest example of your ability to
forgive
and that she is so hard to forgive you
have to understand it's not just about
stoddard
she's this teagan is the susan b anthony
of canceled culture
she relished punching punching down at
anyone
and with her millions of followers she
would have them swarm
it just wasn't on a celebrity she would
be she would happily ruin
anybody's day and remember she was a
model
married to a massive singer who would do
this
but she still got off on the power and
that power infected her followers who
also enjoyed the entertaining
she was a true mean girl so that's why
she's the true test
of of forgiving because i'm i
i'm going to forgive her because i want
to see her second
act will she come to the aid of the next
covington kid
or the next sarah palin or the next type
of person that she would normally
swarm will she instead defend because
i'd like to give her a chance and a
choice
amen barely but dana she
she's been bitten in the backside by the
world that she helped create
well yeah but and it keeps and this is
an extreme example but she's quit
twitter more times than somebody
that i won't mention who would always
quit twitter and then two weeks later be
back
on twitter who could that be they don't
let me just say they don't work at fox
news but um they are a
commentary of a person anyway
the best thing you could do if you're
her i think it's like get off twitter
the other thing is that she would always
tweet about how busy she is yeah
like then okay fine we don't need to be
here and also a last thing on this
this whole issue of encouraging someone
to kill themselves
very serious right because there is a
young woman in jail right now that was
convicted
by a jury of her peers when she
encouraged her boyfriend
to commit suicide and he did it and that
family now doesn't have a
have their loved one obviously that is a
terrible and extreme
example of how far wrong this can go i
just think that for her
i sure apologize whatever but i also
think like why do you need twitter
just don't tweet amen
again uh juan the issue is like
people even if chrissy teigen didn't go
after someone if someone criticized her
then like allison romans was a food
writer
at the new york times who would just
made some comments about
how big chrissy teigen's like cookware
business in her
her food business and book cookbook
business scott
and she was just cr like kind of
critical and
kind of on the side allison roman's
writing about food and the new york
times suspended her and she didn't even
work there anymore
they suspended someone who doesn't work
there or something
and then she left that was what happened
but it was because of comments about
chrissy teigen
well yeah well look i think you know
look i i don't know
why the glee in this thing because
clearly what chrissy teigen did was
wrong
and i think the whole idea of suggesting
someone kill themselves that kind of
cyber bullying it's
it's reprehensible but i don't think
that it
absolves anybody else you know i think
you know people on the right say oh
chrissy teigen
cancel culture well look anybody who
does that kind of thing
they should be held accountable and they
should be condemned
i think that christy tegan should be
punished so to my mind that's the bottom
line here i mean as far as the canceled
culture stuff if she's the queen of
it it's wrong it's wrong for her i think
it was wrong for
gop to go after liz cheney and cancel
her
it's much more serious than canceling mr
potato head i'll tell you that
yeah i mean it's just that's just you
know all these people
parties and glee
that pivot that pivot gave me whiplash
juan
jesse but the problem the problem is
with chrissy teigen is that she went
after somebody anybody everybody
particularly any
anyone who was allied with president
trump you're a conservative remember
she was like bye bye beans with the
boycott goya
she told people to boycott goya because
the ceo went to the white house
well i'm a john legend fan so i don't
really want to criticize his wife too
much
but i will because that's what my job is
so i'll just tell chrissy
to be best okay be best
don't cyber bully people just bully
people on tv
like i do i mean i don't tell people to
kill themselves i just call them corrupt
morons who are destroying the country
but it is funny that the left's being
canceled by the culture that they
created i guess you call it karma
whatever but a bigger point is that
all liberals are saying you did this
you're a bad person
you did they're guilty of all that yeah
they're some of the biggest
nastiest people out there that's the
point so i mean
am i supposed to feel sorry for stodden
i guess we're supposed to take
her side but i'm really i think the true
victim is macy's
i mean macy's is just trying to sell
merchandise and their
and their communication shop is probably
up all night
you know working their tail off on this
i mean that's really the sad thing here
it's the pr
people at macy's and and chrissy's not
really canceled it's not like she's a
nobody it's just one product lawn
distributor she's still rich
she still gets invited to parties so
hopefully john legend doesn't watch this
and hate me
because you're expecting some free
tickets i'm just going to say he's not
watching this
because they're really busy everybody
else is but they're really busy
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else